what's going on man TJ Miller that's
here that Mike sucks
music my side trombone because that's a
big part of my act now it is why did you
decide to it's interesting cuz I don't
play the slide trombone at all when did
you go there I don't know I think it was
high and I had a slide whistle and I was
like in Canada and I was very high and I
was like we need to take this up a notch
right people come to the show right
exactly yeah I get it
I'm the type of guy who carries I love
this [ __ ] train because I live in New
York City now yeah I live in Greenwich
Village and I took the train for the
first time to a gay and as the train
pulled seriously and I was like yeah
serious serious this that is the only
appropriate time possibly get into a
fight over your train whistle because
yeah I do take this [ __ ] seriously the
train is leaving the station and that is
the sound not bring you back to like I
feel like if I were on a train and I
heard a train whistle I'd be back to
like a little kid again look like he
enjoyed childhood or children
actually right until someone complains
yeah I know I might just start doing it
all the time like when a taxi leaves or
anything like I want to incorporate more
musical instruments into my act or is
there part of you that's gonna be like
you know what I want to I want to
actually become a real musician I used
to play the saxophone for a really long
time yeah but now I just play I tell
story whereas in Canada and this the
case for trombone looks like a gun case
and Canada they don't love guns as much
as we do and so they would always be
like what is that and I was like it's a
slide trombone they would say what is it
for it's for strangulation are you in a
band or something and I'm like nope and
they go if they go so what is it for I
took it out and then I would put it
together it looks like in front of the
ticketing agent and then I'm like it's
for this and try and play it and I did
that at the TSA so I tell that whole
story and it's actually it ends pretty
embarrassingly but you'll have to come
to levity live at West Nyack to be able
to see it so smart tonight Saturday and
Sunday it goes straight to the gig from
here that's why you brought it Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday I was announcing
myself throughout nor'easter that make
sense so if you did you spots or
something like if you're doing a
ten-minute spot somewhere are you
bringing the slide trombone and pulling
out I bribed to stay out of New York and
then to this spot there seems like a lot
it's so funny
is it the audience is like why is this
in eight minutes like spending two
minutes putting the [ __ ] thing
together you're jealous of the fact that
musicians have a bunch of [ __ ] they have
to carry around like you got tired of
just showing
seconds without carrying this thing my
limbs are too free yeah but it is pretty
fun too and then I do an impression of
the United States government using the
slide trombone oh that's right pretty
fun that's my only political joke that's
something that I do but and you do it
through a slide trombone yeah I do just
with a slide trombone but what's great
too is like the idea that if people
didn't know who you were they'd be like
what is this like this guy just learned
how to do comedy like why would anybody
do this in ten minutes but now everybody
knows that you've been doing this for a
long time you got specially out there
like exams no reason TJ Miller
specifically yeah it's not like I was
like all right well now I got to start
doing stand-up so I guess I'd better put
some trombone actually was just like
what is the most absurd thing that I can
possibly do and it is the slide trombone
and then somebody pointed out to me the
other day they go will aren't all
trombone slide trombones and that was
good [ __ ] weirdest thing it is a good
point but what a weird bone to pick and
Kate was like you should name it tuba
[Laughter]
one mine people two comedians one mine
what do other comics think of the
incorporation of musical instruments do
they get it or do they get stupid well
I'm the one who's always like sometimes
I trick people especially at colleges
and say that I'm carrot tops cousin
right and so it's just in our blood you
know it's just in the family I think
other comedians in trombone or not kind
of look at my act and they're like what
the [ __ ] is he doing right now what he's
talking about exactly
and but yeah I've been trying boning it
train whistling it you know who knows
what's next and that's great because I
was water speaking of can I have a Red
Bull or water or something there's a
water I can yeah help yourself
your life yeah do you feel like you used
to be nastily sort of life it's gotta be
aged do you feel like since you did its
cheering cats case you're just talking
about do you feel like since you did so
much water stuff on the special I kind
of have to retire water yeah but you
know every so often I'll just like I
just think it's really really fun it
always strikes refreshing - it is
refreshing it's pure life is pure life
yeah and I just always think it's so
funny when people are afraid of getting
wet from water that's gonna dry no
residue
so that's what's so funny go out in the
cold
no but you could but you could handle it
indoors you're getting soaked yeah you
just dry off by the time you have to go
yeah but doing nor'easter eyes kind of
walking around just splashing Pure Life
all over PA oh I'm sure people sit in
the splash zone on purpose it's Shamu
shows yeah you know like so people some
people love it and some people like
yourselves wet yeah if I spray the
audience water like if I do the joke
where I smash the bottle in the water
like sprays out if I do that into the
audience it really pisses people off yes
yes that people don't like to some
people don't like to be wet they're like
now I have water all over me what's
gonna happen it's gonna evaporate in a
little don't no problem laughing at you
when you were always right exactly and
then the one of the biggest criticisms
well I get two criticisms about my HBO
comedy special one is that it's not
funny and then - it's tough is that
people will be like look the water from
the editing is like one time you're wet
on this side of your body and they're
like it's very confusing did you do that
on purpose
it really really disturbs them the lack
of continuity that's [ __ ] up continuity
to do water bits yes very true you know
ridiculous savings I just like that most
comics like specifically like nitpick to
make sure that you cannot tell those are
two shows spliced together whereas
you're like just throw whatever jokes
from wherever and just put them in yeah
I don't know if it's because people are
used to movies and Doug you love movies
I do my Netflix special we did two
tapings but I got high before the first
one and in between so I was like higher
in the second Wow so if you watch it you
can tell the difference between red and
then red again yeah did you use from
both shows yeah yeah yeah and you could
tell the difference if you're looking
for it I did I did meticulously
ridiculous laughs and I warmed up the
night before at a club in Denver which
I'm sure you played comedy work great
club and it was better than the special
so if I do another one I'm going to do
it there that pissed me off so much I
did two shows both of them were better
than the actual special so I don't know
what happens they do a special they they
go out with that same material until the
special yeah see it and then you just
you're kicking yourself because you're
like oh it's going so much better here
than this one this should be imported it
yeah yeah yeah yeah why did I not record
that Omaha funny bone
but I really yeah and I know some people
although the example that I'm about to
give us Pete Holmes and he's a big fan
of Pete Holmes and but he crashing he
recorded two shows and one of them was
so good that he just used that one yeah
I know that be lucky but he is a baby
yeah I mean think about his big like his
first idea was like we'll do a talk show
where we name it after me yeah and then
when that doesn't work out he's like
okay Judd what if we did a sitcom about
me am i five years ago is gonna be like
him in the future
in 2065 that's right at the core so then
you'll go to the present day ya know
it's a lot longer than five years this
character crashing like it's so weird
remember Herman's head yeah that'll be
the last just Pete Holmes his head Pete
Holmes is his head all the different
Pete you know it is though it's supposed
to be about five years ago and
everybody's kind of playing so obviously
really confident five years ago in Yogi
Bear 3d or famous at all when this is
all supposed to be taking place I assume
you're taking like now cuz you're he's
now yeah he's but no he's messing with
stuff it's old Pete and then some
current people but like yeah it's an odd
time all these great comedians just all
cotton to me they all want to help me
out
in America East Coast West Coast
everybody is just what's just New York
everybody's in me I don't remember when
I was like barkings try and get spots at
a club like big comedians like Dave
Attell or something like hey buddy can I
give you a ride to the show
yeah I tried to say hello to Bobby Kelly
and Colin Quinn in Times Square while I
was passing out flyers and they're like
[ __ ] you one of my favorite stories is
that louis c.k this guy in Times Square
came up to him and he's like hey do you
like comedy and Louie's face was on the
floor the people that had performed
there and like you know those clubs that
are like we get drop-ins and crazy
[Laughter]
tonight as a ghost an apparition of
sorts yeah but III loved crashing and
people I think people almost some people
like what I did on that a lot more than
Silicon Valley which premieres this
Sunday and I'm very excited to watch you
are yeah I am as a fan I think it's
gonna be great and I'm not one of those
guys that watches and kind of goes do
you guys watch yourself like and kind of
critique yourself and go i gosh it and
this differently I can't really watch
myself do anything yeah and I'm not
really one of those people so I could
still watch the show but the thing is is
if you watch the show and you're in it
you kind of see that scene and you're
like okay I remember that day and what
was going on with that day and and so
it's just every there's there's you know
the mechanics of making the show is kind
of present as you're watching it but now
I get to watch and I have no idea you
know what it's about or we'll separate
yourself entirely or as part of you
gonna be like that's funny but yeah it
would have been better no no because I
think and here's what's interesting
there was like an article recently that
it seemed like the girl who wrote it is
for the Hollywood Reporter or somebody
just seemed like her her main objective
was to make me sound like the biggest
[ __ ] [ __ ] in the world and so she
used this quote of that where I sounded
like a real dick but one of the
producers said that
and I don't know why but he was like you
know it's the Golden State Warriors of
comedy and I don't think we lost LeBron
James it feels like we lost and then he
named someone else I don't know anything
about sports and my response to that was
I think all those guys are like the
LeBrons of their respective types of
comedy they're all so different right
and so that's kind of what I'm
interested in especially one of my very
good friends Jimmy o yang I'm like
excited that he has more screen time I'm
excited to demand a crew who plays Manik
on it has more screen time Susan Cryer
more screen time it just seemed like the
show was getting so packed and then I
was also my character was becoming so
sad that I would drive home after taping
and kind of being a really sad depressed
really yeah miss your character was the
one that throughout the show like that
character is never going to do any well
no and they and everyone hates him right
you know and so it it was just like 14
hours of other people pretending to kind
of hate me and wish I wasn't there and
this guy trying to make himself useful
and sadly like having no use or the rest
of the cast of Seinfeld was openly
disgusted by crane but I would drive
home and get home and be kind of
depressed and Kate would sort of go why
you seem like you're a bad mood what's
going on I'm like and it was becoming it
was becoming this thing of like they
were really struggling not struggling
but it felt a lot like there was you
know it felt like the writers were
trying to have a reason for Erlich to be
in the show Wow the storylines sort of
incorporated him in weird ways where
they like bring him in because they'd
have to but then get rid of him and then
figure out how to bring him back in and
so I just thought actually the best
thing that I could do for the show was
like step off from the fourth season
because he was becoming sort of
extraneous and it was taking screen time
away
for people who are really funny like
they do not let Susan cry or they give a
lot of stuff but Amanda crew is really
really funny and they just weren't
giving her a lot I think for time
reasons I don't think it had anything to
do with them sort of feeling like she's
not you know talented or useful but so
it just it's for all the right reasons
and then also I just wanted to move to
New York I was just like sick of living
in Los Angeles what are you here for
double more days yeah yeah and I love it
here I come here as often as I can
especially when they say there's a big
storm coming there's nor'easter sure did
you do it nor Easter Egg for canceled
shows and the ones that go off that's
right you said - about like the
reporters trying to make you look like
an [ __ ] cuz it's literally reading an
article yesterday and the headline is
the TJ Miller regrets leaving Silicon
Valley and I'm like really and I read
nasty Exeter's actually read the article
and the quote was from your standup and
it's the joke was sometimes I regret
leaving Silicon Valley cuz I want all
that money for nitrous oxide jokes as
much as misleading headlines it's all
it's all clickbait now I mean that the
about to begin the premiere of Silicon
Valley in the headline was like they
talked about TJ Miller's messy exit and
then he was coming but the you know that
he was coming to set when he was like
intoxicated by like two things one there
like he was showing up sometimes
intoxicated and it's like well first of
all I don't work when I'm intoxicated
and second of all I was because it slows
me down and second of all because I'm
not that good of a comedian where I just
get even more high for the second taping
of your Netflix special
but I also was playing a character who
was always high right and but the reason
that I was like would come exhausted is
because I was doing stand-up every
single night and you know just around
Los Angeles South I would shoot for 12
to 16 hours and then go to stand up and
then you would not get up at like 5:00
in the morning right I had to keep doing
Santa right and then on the weekends I
was doing gigs so I would get back
Sunday night I would figure out a way to
do an earlier show on a Sunday and then
like fly back that night and then the
calls for for television shows and
movies are like 5:00 in the morning 6:00
in the morning that kind of stuff and so
it was just really exhausting and it got
to the point where the math was just
sort of you know my wife is a
mixed-media artist the art world is
completely here I hate I hate Los
Angeles I Love New York
can't get a good trombone and let's say
they're too tinny and so I just felt
like if I was gonna be spending 4 or 5
months out of the year in Los Angeles
every time Kate was gonna visit me it
was just like taking away from what she
was doing because the Los Angeles art
scene is just a dumb pile of burning
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
so there's no reason for her and her
gallerist live in London so they you
know to fly to Los Angeles was going to
be too difficult or and so it just and I
I'm from Denver so I love like Doug
Benson Denver yeah yeah like Vincent I
love a good nor'easter and we had three
this year so that was really exciting
great stuff but I like the cold weather
so it unlike you know some of my friends
in Los Angeles who just can't stand it
if it's in the 60s you know they're just
like oh that's too chilly I don't even
want to go outside I love the weather
yesterday so when you start getting like
who's yesterday right yesterday two days
ago yeah when you start
[ __ ] I do get intoxicated when I'm not
working I am done here I'm going
straight to the Knickerbocker or Spain
drinking establishment here in New York
but what you see this trombone is like a
beer bong I have never thought about but
will definitely with the next show
tonight it both shows I will be beer
bonging through his slide trombone when
you start getting like like when
Deadpool can control how fast the beer
[Laughter]
what's wrong with this guy there's no
part of you that goes like I just can do
these movies I'm not gonna do stand-up
anymore well quits each movie right when
they're done player one in actually in
England and right outside it wonder you
got pine with studios and yeah I'm
really really excited about that movie
people seem to love it and it's kind of
a return to the Spielberg stuff that I
love like I rewatched Lincoln and bridge
of spies and those are both incredible
movies but they're not as much my kind
of movies as like because sometimes you
just want like a popcorn flick just to
sit down yeah and check out and just
have a good time and that's an even
Spielberg has said like this is not a
film this is a movie and it's a movie
based on a book and it was really
interesting to like meet Ernest Cline
I'd never had the experience like for
instance office Christmas party is not
based on a novel and but this you know
it was weird to meet the author and then
the screenwriter and Spielberg and then
also see the three of them kind of
powwow and decide like what is the
truest version to the book but also what
is best for the movie because there's a
lot of things that are very different in
the movie than in the that in the book
and that's because it just worked better
for movie stuff like I think a lot of
the action sequence
they're just much much much bigger in
scale do you have enough self-confidence
that when you find out Spielberg wants
to work with you in a significant way
that it's just like oh cool that's
that's that's about right or is it still
like a trip I have a weird will tell me
a trip but I have a weird thing where
he's sort of I met him in the very
beginning of my career I did the show
called carpoolers and he produced it hmm
and his wife also named Kate also an
artist for some reason I don't know why
but she was a big fan of me on that show
and then I don't know why but Steven
Spielberg I just really tickle his funny
bone and when one of my favorite things
is to I always use his full name when I
talk to him so I'll be like when I was
there after the first day halfway
through the day I said to him Steven
Spielberg I just wanted to tell you
thank you so much for having me in your
movie Steven Spielberg because this is
and he kind of said he was like oh yeah
there was no one else we wrote this part
for you
that was a trip for sure yeah but he you
know it was it was one of those things
where he acknowledges volume Steven
Spielberg I think that that's he thinks
things like that are funny he's actually
kind of silly dude I have a great very
awkward Steven Spielberg story where
that you know has to do with Steven
Spielberg and and so he does this thing
where if it's not working exactly how he
wants it to he'll shoot it which is
something that Michael Bay does also
so he'll actually operate the camera and
then if that still doesn't work this is
all real he'll go like this so be like
okay I think this is a cheetah's moment
can somebody bring me immediately bring
some value Cheetos I think in some ways
like BAE is like this in Wahlberg is
like this is like the I tease them a lot
and I don't think anybody really teases
those people because they're so
intimidated by them or they just feel
like they don't want to offend them and
so and but I think of them sort of as
kings and I'm a jester so why wouldn't I
write you're like Rickles yeah I was
everybody huge he could insult them and
they left Johnny Carson he would just
take cigarettes from his desk yeah so so
I said Steven Spielberg and I said so
Steven Spielberg is this these crunchy
Cheetos or these puffy Cheetos and he's
like oh no no no no crunchy crunchy and
I was like thank goodness if it was
puffy I might have walked off set and
and so then later I kind of teased him
about that and he did he ate the Cheetos
and then he got the shot and they were
able to move on like so was it she does
know yeah you'll see it in the actual
movie there's like orange does a couple
of the scene and water gets on the lens
but I was like was it a Cheetos moment
and he said yeah yeah I mean I really
worked I said do you have a lot of those
because every so often so then I went I
was just watching it was like a day that
I wasn't working but I just wanted to
watch Ben Mendelsohn cuz they're just
him fascinated by him he's this like can
play the scariest psychopathic people
and then you know off-camera
he's just wah yeah he's walking in and
just like singing and he would call
Steven Spielberg dad like daddy's happy
now I'm happy but so I was just watching
him work and then he did it again he was
like alright I think this is a Cheetos
moment can somebody bring me a Cheetos
and an A&W Root Beer and I said man you
really like like Americana stuff and
he's like I don't know I just like
things that are American and I was like
I bet you love American Graffiti
he was like yeah and I said so this is a
Cheetos moment I get to witness a second
Cheetos moment he goes you know what
bring TJ some Cheetos they brought me
some Cheetos so we're both eating
crunchy Cheetos and they're moving the
cameras around it was them it was the
strangest experience I've ever had and
absolutely one of the best but we're
both sort of sitting there and talking
and then we're kind of quiet for a
little while and then he just kind of
looks at me and he takes some of the
Cheetos
out of his bag and he puts them in my
bag and then he just kind of looks at me
and I didn't know what to do
I took some of the Cheetahs out of my
bag and put them in his bag is so real
and he goes he just looks me dead in the
eyes and he goes there
now we're Cheetos brothers and so I
bring that up all the time I'm like
that's amazing you doing buddy well that
was definitely one of the most talked
because it seemed like he thought that I
knew what to do that like Cheetos
Brothers is it just a part of thing yeah
it's a thing and I have never heard of
such a thing no I never heard of
anything like that I've only heard of
Eskimo brothers and that's really really
weird totally different and also
somebody bragged about that to me one
time when I was like you're the grossest